[Música]
en sudán las fuerzas armadas detuvieron
al primer ministro abdalá dogi a otros
altos funcionarios del gobierno el
presidente del máximo órgano de
transición el general abdelfatah al
burhan disolvió el consejo soberano y
declaró el estado de emergencia en el
país uniformados habrían disparado
contra manifestantes que se opusieron a
este levantamiento el ministerio de
información calificó los hechos como un
golpe de estado
la concentración en la atmósfera de co2
el principal gas de efecto invernadero
marcó un nuevo récord durante 2020 pese
a la relativa reducción de nuevas
emisiones que provocó la pandemia la
alerta la lanzó hoy la organización
meteorológica mundial de cara a la con
26 que comienza un domingo que viene
diez años de prisión para un alemán dax
integrante del autodenominado estado
islámico por crímenes de guerra y contra
la humanidad un tribunal de múnich la
condenó por esclavizar y dejar morir a
una menor yazid y en irak la fiscalía
pedía cadena perpetua en un juicio que
comenzó en abril del año 2019
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en ciudadana
porque el ejército puso bajo arresto
domiciliario al primer ministro abdalá
hamd junto a otros líderes del gobierno
de transición el servicio de internet
fue interrumpido en el país y los
militares dispararon en contra los
opositores que se opusieron en las
calles a este levantamiento el
ministerio de información calificó estos
hechos como un golpe de estado todo esto
ocurre tras semanas de tensión en ese
país africano en medio de una profunda
crisis económica veamos
era frágil y ahora ha llegado a su fin
el general militar anunció el fin del
gobierno de transición
hemos decidido decretar el estado de
emergencia en todo el país segundo
disolver el gobierno y el consejo
soberano permanecemos sin embargo
apegados a los acuerdos internacionales
firmados durante el mandato del gobierno
interino y la transición hacia un estado
civil
las calles fueron tomadas por los
manifestantes tan pronto como se
difundió la noticia del arresto del
primer ministro abdalá hunt doc y la
mayoría de los miembros del gobierno
civil
hombre me dio lo que está haciendo el
ejército es una traición a los
ciudadanos ahora es importante que todos
los ciudadanos sudaneses actúen y salgan
a la calle para impedir que las fuerzas
militares lleven a cabo las operaciones
whitfield de araba bolas y que haya
bajas querían a trabajando que está bajo
arresto domiciliario y llamó a la
ciudadanía a salir a las calles para
defender la transición democrática
vigente desde la caída de omar al bashir
en 2019 desde la embajada estadounidense
en jartúm pidieron la continuidad de un
gobierno civil y la unión africana y el
presidente francés abogaron por la
liberación de los detenidos
francia condena con la mayor firmeza el
intento de golpe militar y sudán expreso
nuestro apoyo al gobierno de transición
sudanés y hago un llamado a la
liberación inmediata y al respeto a la
integridad del primer ministro y de los
dirigentes civiles tras asaltar la sede
de la radio y la televisión sudanesa y
cortar el internet en el país el
presidente del consejo soberano aseguró
que designará a un gobierno de personas
competentes hasta las próximas
elecciones previstas para julio de 2023
hace dos días una facción sudanesa
advirtió de la inminencia de un golpe de
estado en este país y ha sumido en una
profunda crisis económica
cambiamos ahora información dejamos
áfrica para hablar del cambio climático
porque la organización meteorológica
mundial aseguró que la concentración en
la atmósfera de dióxido de carbono el
principal gas de efecto invernadero
marcó un nuevo récord y se sitúa en 413
partes por millón esto en el año 2020 el
informe se conoce a pocos días de que
comience en glasgow en escocia la cumbre
contra y sobre el cambio climático la
organización advirtió que los niveles de
co2 en la atmósfera son 149 por ciento
superiores a los de la era preindustrial
y dada a la larga duración de ese gas
puede contribuir a un aumento de las
temperaturas durante décadas la agencia
de la onu también advirtió que al
término 2021 las concentraciones de co2
volverán a marcar niveles récords
hoy hablamos de gases de efecto
invernadero y hemos vuelto a batir
récords en los principales gases de
efecto invernadero dióxido de carbono
metano y óxido nitroso y esta tendencia
negativa que venimos observando antes
durante décadas air también ha
continuado advino beringer y ford ford y
kate first continuo show y es que hoy
justamente el primer ministro británico
boris johnson admitió sus dudas sobre el
eventual éxito de la con 26 está durante
una conferencia de prensa y en compañía
de niños el 'premier' aseguró que teme
que en esta cumbre que comienza el 31 de
octubre no se logren los acuerdos
necesarios para limitar el aumento
generalizado de la temperatura global
veamos lo que dijo como we will smith y
bruce post brett gardner hereu
necesitamos que la mayor cantidad de
personas posibles se comprometen con las
emisiones neutras cero para que no estén
produciendo demasiado dióxido de carbono
para mediados de siglo ahora yo creo que
puede hacerse será muy muy dura esta
cumbre aquí estoy muy preocupado porque
podría salir mal
no obtener los acuerdos que necesitamos
rimet sweeney y ojalá esta cumbre con
muchas otras no se quede solo en papel
cambiamos de información desde hoy les
presentamos una serie de reportajes
especiales previo a la con 26 la cumbre
del clima que se va a realizar en
glasgow como ya lo estábamos adelantando
es el próximo domingo en italia la isla
de sicilia es una de las regiones más
impactadas por los efectos del
calentamiento global los veranos se
hacen cada vez más calientes con graves
consecuencias para la agricultura este
verano los apicultores en particular han
sufrido los efectos de este clima
extremo reportando grandes pérdidas en
su industria nuestra corresponsal en
italia natalia mendoza nos preparó el
siguiente informe veamos
para este apicultor de las situaciones
nefasta
miren todas estas colmenas todas vacías
totalmente abandonadas por las colonias
de abejas que tenían aquí pero uno de
los cerca de 2.000 apicultores
sicilianos nunca ha visto algo similar
este verano perdió más de la mitad de
sus abejas cuando una ola de calor sin
precedentes golpeó la región
este verano fue una tragedia por el
calor extremo las temperaturas se
acercaron a los 50 grados muchas de las
abejas murieron o dejaron las colmenas
que se convirtieron en infiernos
levantaban forma como consecuencia de
estas temperaturas récord los incendios
devastaron la zona miles de hectáreas
fueron consumidas por el fuego
destruyendo la vegetación que es
esencial para las abejas estos insectos
a su vez son vitales para la
polinización de tres cuartos de los
cultivos
mira todo estos árboles se han ido para
siempre tenemos que replantear todo
significa la destrucción de un bosque
como este resultará en la desaparición
de la fauna y de las pasturas que son
fundamentales para las abejas con ingrid
a dipascali perle a estos incendios han
destruido las floraciones de finales de
verano y principios de otoño
sin flores no hay néctar para alimentar
a las abejas fortunato apicultor durante
28 años no tiene otra alternativa más
que alimentar artificialmente a las
sobrevivientes por primera vez
esta es una mezcla azucarada se la damos
para contrarrestar la falta de fuentes
naturales de alimentación de otra manera
corremos el riesgo de que la colonia de
abejas muera durante el invierno
pero esto no ha sido suficiente para
salvar la producción de miel que ha
caído en un 70% este año en la isla una
crisis sin precedentes que ha obligado
al gobierno local a declarar el estado
de emergencia para la industria apícola
en sicilia seguimos hablando del planeta
del volcán la cumbre vieja la isla
española de la palma que continúa en
erupción las autoridades ya contabilizan
unos 2 edificios totalmente consumidos
por la lava y más de siete mil personas
que han tenido que abandonar sus hogares
ya son cinco semanas de erupción y los
expertos del tema en la destrucción del
cono secundario y se muestran
preocupados por la ruta que tomará la
lava el aumento de la actividad coincide
con la detección de niveles récord de
dióxido de azufre en este volcán
o un tribunal de múnich condenó a 10
años de cárcel a una alemana ex
integrante del autodenominado estado
islámico por la muerte de una menor
yazid y en irak la mujer de 30 años fue
acusada de complicidad e intento de
asesinato crímenes de guerra y contra la
humanidad el juzgado la encontró
culpable de dejar morir de sed a una
niña de 5 años esclavizada en irak la
fiscalía exigía cadena perpetua mientras
que la defensa pedía un máximo de dos
años de prisión por militancia en grupo
terrorista se trata de uno de los
primeros juicios en el mundo sobre los
crímenes contra los yazidíes una minoría
perseguida por los yihadistas en siria y
también en irak
y creo que para una madre que perdió a
su hija no hay sentencia que sea lo
suficientemente dura nuestra cliente
también cree esto para ella es
importante y lo dijo durante el juicio
que el mundo sepa quién es el
responsable y hoy recibió esta decisión
o en sant estoy ensayaron acción sobre
home y la farmacéutica estadounidense
moderna anunció que su vacuna contra el
cob y 19 se fijasen niños entre 6 y 11
años datos de los ensayos clínicos de
más de 4700 menores revelaron una
respuesta fuerte en niveles de
anticuerpos y un perfil de seguridad
favorable la compañía planea presentar
en breve los datos para lograr su
aprobación ante los organismos
reguladores del mundo
seguimos hablando precisamente de la
pandemia pero en asia las autoridades
chinas anunciaron nuevos confinamientos
para miles de residentes del norte del
país y pidieron a los habitantes de la
capital beijing limitar sus movimientos
debido a estos nuevos brotes de kobe 19
en al menos 11 provincias desde beijing
precisamente nuestro corresponsal adrián
foncillas con todos los detalles sobre
esta noticia veamos
el norte de china sufre un rebrote de
más de un centenar de casos en una
semana y el gobierno y alertado de que
la situación empeorará en los próximos
días el rebrote se originó en mongolia
interior en grupos de turistas locales y
se ha extendido a 11 provincias el
gobierno ha accionado el protocolo de
alarma y está practicando análisis a la
población de las zonas afectadas también
canceló ayer en el último minuto la
maratón que debía celebrarse en luján el
presunto origen de la pandemia tampoco
se celebrará la maratón que estaba
prevista el domingo que viene en pekín a
pesar de que en la capital sólo se han
detectado cuatro casos a los pequineses
se les ha recomendado que no viajen si
no es totalmente imprescindible a los
llegados de las provincias afectadas se
les exige una pcr negativa realizada en
los dos últimos días china se ha quedado
sola en su estrategia de tolerancia cero
con el virus cuando el mundo está
abriendo paulatinamente sus fronteras y
aceptado convivir con el virus a china
en cambio le preocupa la alta capacidad
de contagio de la nueva variante delta y
no quiere
rebrote le puede arruinar los juegos
olímpicos de pekín que se celebrarán el
año que viene o el congreso del partido
comunista
amnistía internacional anunció el cierre
de sus oficinas en hong kong por la ley
de seguridad nacional impuesta por
beijing el cierre se producirá antes que
termina 2021 todo el trabajo de la
oficina regional con conesa se llevará a
cabo desde nuevas ubicaciones mientras
tanto varias organizaciones no
gubernamentales además de sindicales y
políticas han cerrado sus oficinas por
la norma que restringe las libertades en
el territorio semiautónomo
y seguimos con información del huracán
rick de categoría 2 en escala de saffir
simpson que tocó tierra durante la
madrugada en méxico y dejó fuertes
lluvias en el estado de guerrero aunque
se espera que se pierda fuerza en las
próximas horas el servicio meteorológico
nacional estima que el fenómeno podría
generar deslaves e inundaciones en las
zonas de michoacán y de guerrero por lo
que el gobierno ha instado a la
población a extremar las precauciones y
a seguir las recomendaciones de las
autoridades de protección civil
y nosotros en fracción de 4 seguimos
dando seguimiento al mes de
sensibilización sobre el cáncer de mama
que se celebra en todo este mes de
octubre y vamos a el salvador para así
conocer la historia de elizabeth
martínez venta campeona nacional de
automovilismo que dedica parte de sus
esfuerzos a la causa de la prevención de
esta dolencia que afectó a su círculo
familiar más cercano el siguiente
reportaje es preparado por nuestro
corresponsal vladimir chamorro veamos
desafiar las curvas del autódromo es su
pasión la velocidad con la que compite
elizabeth le ha llevado a ganar muchas
carreras en todas el símbolo rosa icono
de la lucha contra el cáncer de mama
sale triunfante aunque sea un poquito yo
odio a alguien que mira esto les tiene
que mover reales tiene que mover aunque
sea una minoría que yo pueda cambiarle
su pensamiento y de estar al pendiente
desde su cuerpo y de su vida
favorito la stampa rosa acompaña a
elisabeth desde que es piloto
profesional hace 8 años en
reconocimiento a su hermana que
sobrevivió al cáncer de mama y para
visibilizar la causa
porque tal vez a través de mí muchas
personas van a vivir
van a prevenir y le van a ganar la
batalla al cáncer
otra causa en la que participa elizabeth
es la donación de cabello por tercera
vez se lo cortará para que pueda ser
usado en pelucas para las mujeres que
están recibiendo quimioterapia
porque no están exentos de cáncer de
mama
en honor a todos ellos ya muchas y está
en esta lucha para ello
la pentacampeona nacional está
comprometida por completo no solo a
ganar medallas sino también a continuar
siendo eco de la prevención de una
enfermedad que en el salvador tiene una
incidencia de 40 casos por 100.000
habitantes
y esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro informativo en france 24
continúen con nosotros feliz resto de
ella para todos hasta pronto
[Música]